[Music]
and
good afternoon everyone
I'm glad to see the room so full
especially for this session of being half
empty but I'm glad about the one so full
because it's a tensor flow and
machine learning session and honestly you already
know that this  it's something like a
guest and committees this is
this is for people
this is for few people
[Music]
the session we're going to do today is and I
'm going to give you a bit of a crash test of I
'm going to be the instrument that we're going to
use together to learn about
tensor flow and how to configure
neural networks it
is a session that martín corner prepared
the initial one lasted four hours then he
managed to reduce it to two and I am going to
do it for you in 40 minutes so it is a good
challenge that we have together because  you have to
try to understand a lot of things about
machine learning and on top of that do it much
faster than normal so good
for this because of this time constraint
and also because later people are going to talk
back to the club  ber that they
will really tell you how they do this type
of project every day because what we will
do is that if you have questions
you can ask me later while we are
going to get something to eat
well I do not know if you know it surely
yes because you will have seen it and you have
worked with it or open it up take a look
at this it is one of the ex-mythical data
to learn how to do topics the machine
learning of artificial intelligence
has been going on for more than 20 years and people have had a
great time playing with the mix
basically you have a data  set of 60 thousand
diddy hits drawn numbers drawn
in and scanned all with the same
format all with the same quality and
bone mark ready to train
classified to be able to train and
from there what has happened is that
during the last 20 years
there has been  a lot of people who have taken
that data set and have tried to improve what
I note apart from this data set I
also recommend that you take a
look at loading cake that  angel l
is one of google's latest acquisitions
and here you can find two
very interesting things, a lot more
data set, surely closer to the
problems that you have to consider
beyond just recognizing numbers,
but also other very creative solutions
very creative solutions that
we do you take it out of my beard it's not worth it
and we'll come back
in that you're going to be able to find also
many of the solutions that apply
to how to do the basic things
activation functions or how
many of the problems are solved
then each  lend a hand
[Music]
I'm your am crash tester and I just got
the problem and I'm
trying to solve for the first time how to
do the 60,000 classification problem
I've read all the theory you
can imagine you don't read the  all the
automatic classification theory and you
stay in the first papers and in
one of the first papers what they
tell you is that soft max is a  good
mechanism to classify and now
we call the data set inside
what we have in the data set what we
have are 60,000 images as I was
saying 28 by 28 pixels
and what we have is the drawing in this
case what you see is 18  from there
what we are going to do is to simplify
we are going to put everything in a single vector
and what we have is then the first row
of pixels the second row of pixels
and we join them all until we have a
single vector from  there we
apply soft max because soft max
because it seems like a fairly
simple way to be able to compute this process
if you really think about it here what we
have done with soft max when doing the
normalization process what we have
done in each of the neurons  it is if
we paint it in a line, hit a
number between 0 and 1 to each of
the digits, that is, for example, 4 is
approximately, that is, in 4 this
specific 4 that I have in front of me now or this
specific fact that I have ah  ora before it
is 0 23 48 a number and that would be the
result of executing only max in this
step ok what happens to us also
with soft max that what we
want is that it put them for the
ten classes that we have and that we  give a
value between 0 and 1 to be able to carry out the
classification process, it
is
good to do it one by one, vector by vector, it
is too easy and to make it more
entertaining and that you can think about it better
and that we can use the power that
modern computers give us, well  what
we are going to do is pass them the
images 100 by 100 when we are
doing the training set because of
the 60,000 images we will take about
10,000 more or less to train because when we
pass those 10,000 we will divide them into
blocks of 100 and then what we
will do is  a small multiplication of
matrices, something in which it is very efficient,
tense flow, and what we are going to do is
multiply
the image that comes to us by the weight, which
is what we are trying to opti  mizar
within the automatic classification process
plus a berry ok with that what
we are going to do is we are going to discover
we are going to find the different
playboy the different trees plus
the fences what is happening to us that the
array of berries we
need to be one  matrix and for
it to be exactly the same as the 10 the
10 classes that we are trying to predict what we are
going to need is that this matrix
has to be initialized with several zeros
so that later it fits us in the
different fences although in reality in
many cases we will have the same fences
for each of the numbers
[Music]
here we see how they are filled
and what I was telling you in the same 10
go although we will have the same 10
berries we need it to be a matrix that
there is a very easy function in a pi
well most of you will like it  python you
have come here I understand that
most like python in amp and
you have a function that is the broadcast
that simply by adding the arrays and
tc that in a way  to automatic and this would be
the more or less way to describe the or
the way to describe it within the
soft max within python what we are
looking for are the predictions that are
those 10 that is, sorry those 100 images
that we have passed for prediction by the
10 different states that I have for
each one of the numbers, he applied the
soft max function, he passed him the images, the
content that I really have, the weights,
which is what I want to estimate, and
lastly, the valleys, is that I also want to
estimate them,
that was the way of  write it
mathematically this would be the way to
write it within the tensor flow as
you can see very similar efe extensor flow a
little later we will see the code
and nn is the reference for neural
networks the good thing about tensor flow is that it
is a decoupled model first we are going to
do everything  the initialization part of
the objects that we are going to use of the
arrays that we are going to need later
we are going to do the configuration of the
details that you want  Let's go more low level
for example of the type of hardware or if
we use gpu and cpu step is the type of
thing and then we are going to tell it to
execute in this case what we are
doing is the first step that we
simply define the arrays
where  I want to write
very well we have seen the first step soft
max but I need somehow to
have a mechanism to estimate those w
those weights that we have said and those berries
how do I do it I need a function that
tells me at all times if I am
doing it right or  if I'm doing it wrong
and that allows me to do the
bach propagation process that we will see a little
further on then what you are
seeing in the above in the current
probability swan hot in code that is
when we are telling you that this
number is a  6, that is, we have passed the
to tell it that this image is that of a
6. We pass the image of that vector with
all
the 728 numbers and then we pass it to it
and we are passing it the probability
that that  be the number 6 which in this case
is 1
on the other hand we will have those that we have
calculated the probabilities calculated
in this case what they will do is go from 0 to
1 because they are not 0 because you will see it a
bit later never start in
initialization  we initialize them
to zero because well because if we
initialize them to zero it would be very
easy to 1 it would be very easy for them to
remain in those extreme values we need
o initialize them to a small
and positive number two t
ings two notes to keep an eye o
them I am a  crash test friends I
am not doing any more I have not started to
do super research but
I am simply reading the
typical papers that here it is interesting to
understand well how precision and
record work because if you do not understand well how it
will work in the process of
classification and how you are going to collect the
feedback from the classifier some of the
things that are going to come later are going to
cost especially when you want to
modify them for  ro let's make a separate note a
recommendation for you to take a
look at it okay and then once we have
trained with this what we will find
is called cross entropy because use
by center pine use the fingers or
other mechanisms to find the
differences the errors error square
mean  and other
mathematical instruments well because cruise
works in tropic it is one of the standards
in this type of system and then when you
see in the tests that we are going to do
that I am going to share with you you will see
how if we use pi as the center we
get a reasonably
good result  those new things also to
define or to or to validate but
I feel that you will be able to vary in your
data ex and surely if you use
export data
where there are texts large volumes of
text with center pi it would be one of those that
you would have to consider because it will
be worth it or not  it would be as efficient as l2
or as as
or here if I can ask you a favor if it
gives me  is when you click on the video I
wave you because the demo will gain a lot of spark
if it doesn't give the next one I'll explain
how it is we can because we have
great
skills well that's the training process
that video you're watching is very
fast but I know  it has given a clue as to what
we were doing
thank you very much it has given you a clue as to what we
were doing
something excuse me
go to the area or not
sectarian
thank you
very much thank you very much to the people but from the
video you saw that the ally
well what has he done  passed there very
quickly in five seconds what we have
done has been to spend all three of the
entire training set through
the process what you are seeing in
front of you is a visualization that
martin kroner made to visualize
what is happening in the process  in tensor
flow we have another very cool
tool called tensor board if you are going to
consider any
moderately serious tensor flow
project please take a look  to tighten the
sensor work because you are going to save a
lot of work, which is exactly what you
had to do here, part of the work you
have to do, which is that in the code
you will have to spit out the correct messages in the log,
which are the ones you
want to measure, but  We help each other with
many more metrics that are already
included. Well, those who have
developed a project and are already
included help us. What can we see here
with three main measures? In the first
place, we have the top
left, you have cura and precision.  and what
we can see is the precision the
precision in two sets on the one hand
whenever we do a
training process we have to choose the
data set with which I want to train
and then the data set with which
I want to vary validate the set of  Testing
is important, how you make the selection
of these two sets must always be
random, there must not be a go,
for example, a go by date or a
go by client, a v  territorial ayas
all that kind of thing can
annoy training and in this case what we
can see is that from the beginning
very quickly before 200 the precision has already increased a
lot and it has already
managed to improve we can also see
in the next one which is the  cross center
pig and that is where we are following
how the loss has gone what we can
see is that it has dropped quite quickly
although it remains at 30% which man
is quite heavy if you think about it and
then as it has a lot of variance it does
not  a lot of variability makes very
big jumps it is not in tune so to
speak in the next one you can see the
training day digits I have passed this set
of 100 numbers and in this set in 100
numbers even in the training set I have been
wrong that is when they are  giving
a training set I have been wrong in
some when recognizing it and then in the
next one in the digits bay test that you see
that there are quite a few in which
it is certain that it is 92 percent than in
this  case in the red ones it is the other way around than
in the one above and well it would not be bad
not good the next 2 waits what we
are seeing is the distribution of the
weights the weight has to be between minus
one and one to fit the threads
so  they can be between negative two and two
and that is simply the distribution of
all from zero to a thousand
training cases well what do you say 92% is
good it is not bad we have made it a
classifier capable of looking at numbers and in a
very small piece of code that  you will see
now we are able to classify ok
now what would happen to us we would go to
real life and then when you go to
real life man if you start to recognize
postal codes and you make a mistake one
in ten if we take into account
that there are six  digits you are making a
mistake one out of every two times that it
is recognizing zip code, that is, you
fail a lot, you
have to understand that here we recognize
digit by digit, not packets of digits,
with which we are going to make a mistake  car as
soon as we collect 10 we are making
mistakes once we go it fails a lot
92% the project manager on duty would
pull his hair out and the client
would tell us this does not work it does not fail me
a lot then we would have to
improve our objective so that you
do  an idea to overcome 99 percent
and we are going to achieve it
I hope
the next thing we have is how
tensor flow is initialized this is what it
said d
decoupled the decoupled model this
decoupled model comes in handy then
when you want to do two things put
many servers to  do the
training part make us the
distributed training and also
when you bring it to claudio ml so that
we can do that part of the
process and then when you
start putting things like now I have gp I use I
don't have examples and you want to do that kind
of  evidence
that in fact I know that voltees
clubs have done quite
well here we have the functions that
we have defined to  Before initializing let's
create the place holder for the size
we initialize it with the size of
each of the images 28 x 28 as we have
white black of the 1 at the end is 1 because it
can only be either 0 or 1
[Music]
with the rest and  with the rest so what we
do is fill in the variables for
the weights and the fences
the next thing we do is put the
part of the success metrics what we
said about cross entropy we put the
part of the model that is the first line
with the images to  planned we do the
next phase which is a place holder
to put them in a huge matrix to be
able to put the correct answers and
then what we will do between the two between
yi and prima what we do is the calculation
of cruise en tropic that we have said
before
we do a sum of  cross entropy errors
will always be a function of
increasing mass it is an
interesting function because it is always based on a
decreasing function and it will allow
us to help us because it has a mu vector  and of
course it always goes down so in
the following phases you will see that it
is quite useful with that what we are going to
achieve is the following that if it is
correct and what is the level of accuracy
as the center pi chorus told you what it
allows us  in a very simple way
because it marks a very clear vector that is
a descending vector it will allow us to
optimize the next step here
what we are going to do ok I'll give you the
images I see how many I made a mistake with I
go back and change the weights and
the berries to see if with that we get
any improvement that is the
broadcasting part here it is very interesting
tensor flow and it has been one of those things
that has radically changed how
these types of systems were made before that
is what you have to do
you have to  calculate derivatives of
each of the points do
you remember more or less we have said 700
eighty-odd not by ten that are the
digits well then we have to calculate
about 8000 derivatives in each  one of
the steps
you know because you have seen that kind of
thing there are different ways to calculate
the derivatives partial
derivatives numerical derivatives indeed in
this case estimates are not made but
they are calculated the derivatives are calculated
and then the numbers are replaced
with which is  even more
intensive in calculation it is one of the
most intensive options in calculation but
the good thing is that the quality when going through
the gradient this is going to be much
better here is another important point that
are the steps of the e-learning rate think
about that in one  decreasing function no at
some point it has to go back up
no more then that decreasing function
if I go through it it will always go
down until a point where
it starts to grow again so if
I make some very large steps it is
another thing  typical that you can optimize
some of the very large steps, for
example 0.1 instead of 0.03, what is very
easy for me to do is to go from one side  or
to the other of the function and I
never find the minimum and I think that
I am at the minimum, which is a flat minimum,
that is one of the interesting points and
here what we would have after each
of the trending steps that would be the
steps  of training
and this is the tensor flow code with
this that part that I said before about
the
this part that I told you before about
the matrices sorry about the
initialization in phases you can see it
here with the session we do it is equal to
tensor  flow point session we ask for the
session that we have been configuring
all the time and then what we do is
session get to work run you with
the initialization ok this is what I was telling you about
the decoupled model this is
where you can finally do all the
computation  Of everything that we have been
configuring so far, the only thing that
we have done has been to reserve pieces of
memory to put the different
variables
and then we start the training what
we do  s is to tell it to execute at the
6 run points in the part of the train and we
tell it to execute this train step that
we have defined before with the
scnt gradient and we pass it the dictionary with the
train in data where I have all the data
so that it can build the  the
vectors from there what we do is the
next step which is to calculate the success
that we say the same thing to the session
at runtime what is the cure that
we want to fill in what is the cross on
top and what do we want to calculate and what is it  the
cruise function in tropic that we have
pardon and we pass him the dictionary with
the training data so that he can
calculate the differences
this is the complete code there
are very few lines if you have not done it you will
have programmed with it e-mail and
neural networks or  you will have made neural networks
with 11
and they were not like that small of small it never
does not hit you you go debugging and putting a
lot of things that really did not
help you at all and here the truth is that it
is a lot  easier for me this
is the typical non-bréyner that helps you
decide to switch to tensor flow
well let's review what we have
done is soft max cross entropy and
the mini batch part we have done as a
base of images that we pass to it  every time
but up to now we have not done
serial neural networks we have done the
smallest step which is soft max in one in a
single step this is not one euro per
network
this is effectively you have read the
first five papers and you have stayed
there we can take a step further, which
would be the first to try to improve that
92% of mud higher up and the second
step to try to take full
advantage of the neural networks
and then what we
would do would be to define several layers five layers
well that's too much  surely this
could be done maybe with less than 34 is
the typical thing to try and to do
experiments
martin khor no I didn't comment on it here
because I didn't comment on it when I prepared the
session but  there is a very
interesting part that is the whole part of auto
ml and to automatically discover this
type of parameters because you are going to
find it in what you were
in python tensor flow the
packages that you were there you are going to find
all that artillery and it goes  to help
automatically find the
parameters that are optimized one of the
parameters to be optimized is the number of
layers that I put
ok layers of neural networks I will have
to decide now in some way that is how
it looks like this piece that I am
seeing or  no and if it goes to the next
level for me or a network is not worth it to
do that what we are going to use is an
activation function that is the seat
again on our crash test of
I have read the 15 papers yesterday on
functions  of activation well
one that I know of the venues has read me and I have
stayed with the series because it seemed
better to me and it follows it very
well because it is what is good about it because it is derivable that it
goes from 0 to 1 because of the way it  it has no 1
match for 1 higher than x and
being derivable in everything because it seems
reasonable yes it is true that for
many due to biological excesses at the
beginning
the mathematicians or the doctors who
dared to decide if that was a chair
or a net  They said that this was a
chair that looked better. It
still seems incredible to me that we are
going to say what the
activation function of a neuron is. Really,
the ones we have here don't, and in the
last step we have to leave the
soft max because  the soft max because they are
going to help us to have only the 10
classes and make it between 0 and 1 which would be
the last activation step
again for reviewing a little tensor flow
and helping them as the kastles of what we
do with tensor flow in this case
is that we start to initialize
the first step which is very similar to what
you had seen before we make the
weights of the first layer
we define the variables with the size
we need in this case what
h  What we do is that for it to be filled in we
apply it we say to tensor flow
tensor flow calculates for me a
truncated normal a normal a normal distribution
of numbers of this size 28 x 28
that the standard deviation is 0.1
so that you give me small numbers the
mean is  always small numbers
between 0 and 0 with 2 one thing
once we have defined that layer what we
do is that in the next one
we pass the previous one and so on
we do not have w 2 b 2 and now what we
do is we have defined them all and
now  you will see it in the code as what we
do is pass the previous one in this
case what we do is define x what
is
the function that we want to estimate the
function of the weights that
we want to reach at the end and then what we
do is go  defining each one of the
layers with the weights and the one that we want to
estimate that is x and we add
the weights and the fences of the previous ones
to what is the truth that is quite
simple to understand also here  tensor
flow is again quite
intuitive I have a five-layer network
I have five lines of code it's a
fairly simple thing to understand and to
follow well we're not going to give the video
again because I don't have but apart from
I'm not going  let's mess around with the video
what would happen to us if we execute
this it wouldn't be fatal it wouldn't be fatal we
made a mistake from the book of
classics the ceremony was going well I don't know
what's going wrong because when we start
executing it we realize  that the
precision is in 0 60 and peak well
below what it had before and also the
cross entropy and the loss is brutal
we are practically in 100% of
cases that it fails so there has to be
some better alternative and this is where
it ends  to rescue us from what is for
all the lights the best form of the
best activation function as well as in
other things you may have more doubts yes
it is true that with a clock for all
the papers all all the things that  I have
seen all the times that I had to
execute it, there is a leap in two moments,
on the one hand,
on the one hand, in the quality of how it
does it, it is much more effective and much
better, and the second is in time, it is
much more efficient, derive clock
function  clock what to do with the
series that is what we have with clock
because what we have is 1000 again
within fn of the
tensor flow neural network package we have the
clock function directly prepared and
what the function is going to do for us
clock, well, it's a fun line function
that below zero
in negative numbers is always zero and
in any positive number
above zero only one will come out, it is not
differentiable at a point that is zero,
but hey, this is a detail  mathematician
that in the end is fixed when
the clock packets are made when you make the
code to set up the network well you solve
that function error so to speak
another interesting thing with light that
this is an after the [ __ ] standard
too
[Music] this
is what has happened to us with the clock we
have tried activation functions
we have realized that it is the good one and it
is a bit of learning that is
shared with others I have not seen it
yet  none no paper or
no theoretical explanation I have not chosen
all of them obviously but I have not yet seen
any paper no
mathematical theoretical explanation that explains why
one yes and the other no although there are more and
more people investigating these topics
it is worth what we are  It has happened when
activating when using the clock because the
precision has increased a lot and we have
practically returned to the levels
at which it was and the loss in the
function of loss of concentration pi
has lowered us to reasonable levels and
even better than before  before
agreed we were around 30
percent and now we are not moving
around 20 there is a dramatic improvement
but if we zoom in we find that
the clock t  It has some details a little
curious it
does not get 100% of acura if it is still
in the test set this is strange if you are
doing if I am giving you some to
train and with those same ones I try man
you should accept me one hundred percent something
happens and curious and  the other curious thing is
that the variance is very go because
we are already talking about some very
important jumps normally when you
count very large jumps in cross entropy functions as
soon as you start
adding much more data to the
data set those jumps are already  enormous and
normally what ends up happening to you is
that the loss function grows over
time, that is something to
control
very well, so how can we improve it
when we have very large jumps in
this cross entropy function, what happens to us
is in this function  what I was telling you
before, do not imagine a
decreasing parabolic function because what happens to you
is that you are making jumps that are too
big,
so the trick is to make smaller
jumps  years
and the definitive trick is to start taking
big steps and as you
go forward reduce the steps
start at 0.003 for example and
then as you go forward and
reduce it to seven zeros and 11 for
example as you give it cases
of training is what is called the
learning rate and that is fine,
thank you very much for that
[Music]
come on, we give the video focus, we have a
harness,
well, you can see it perfectly, as in the
training digits, it directly fails, much
less the cases in which they are
failing are  much less in 3d and
you can also see that it is much less in the
cure so it has gone directly
to 0 98 from the beginning and the
entropy man prison until 2000 has gone
very well then it is true that it has
come up and then  if you look
at the acura if what has happened to us is
that as soon as it has given it enough
training cases, that is, if it gives it
two thousand training cases, surely
it gives 80 90 100 about  Well, he found,
given more than 60 70 ones, he already begins to
predict well with the following ones
that I give him, it's okay, that's what we
've seen, that it has had a
very clear direct effect than that of hernán
rate, that simply by changing the when
I  I walk this parabolic
decreasing function when you see it going
when I start doing it in smaller steps I
get much more precision and
the back propagation place the weights in
a much more efficient way
we still have
high error variance and now and here we see that it
is a lot  smaller yes it is true
that we are not given this effect that I was
telling you that the lcross entropy error
grows if we have managed to make it much
more stable that it does not have a
tremendous variance but it is growing that is with
2000 if you realize it has  reached
its optimum point, that is, twice as many
cases as its optimum point gives it training,
but from then on I have
reached 100,000, the ten thousand cases,
sorry
if 1  0,000 cases
is starting to grow a lot if I add
the 60 thousand if I add another 25
we will surely be at 30 or 40
percent of the error is too big we
would have to find some way to
optimize it and the way to optimize it or
what the normally says  literature is
that we are doing over feet in when
an error function grows when I give it
is very intuitive it is very easy to
understand when an error function
grows when I give it new cases what
happens to me is that my weights were very
good for my case  of testing but when
I keep giving it new cases it does not
make it smaller I already have all my
test cases reflected in my
neurons in the neurons of my
neural network that I manage to adjust very
well to my test cases
because because  they make peace totally
separated but they fit very well to
the cases of non-general testing and
it is also worth
how this is solved and this is another one of
those very cool techniques that
saves  an lives drop out drop out is also a
lot of fun because what it does is that
you charge your neurons and you let
the ones that remain become stronger,
which is basically the technique, because what
we do is tell him in
training, take 75% off me  85%
the technique if you think about it is very wild
because I have defined a huge neural network
and now it turns out that what my
neural network wants to do is make it
smaller in training it is worth the
function again in a florez tensor in
the neurons networks  drop out and what
we do is that we pass the data to it
and we tell it that in this case make a
kit, that is, keep alive 75%
of these other variables with
which you can play quite well and there is
quite a lot of cool left to do  tests okay
once we have done the training in
execution when we get to the
test cases we put all of them we don't
just put the ones that we have used the
training and then
what is what what we can see q  ue when we
put him
but
I do not have the following words the
dreams do not improve with the over fitting
we have added sorry it is not true true
here we have improved the in this last one
that you see here in the last step what
you are seeing here on the top
right  and on the top right is the improvement
we have had by adding the drop
out well it doesn't seem like much it doesn't seem like
much yes it is true that what we
have is an improvement of 3% 4%
we have managed to improve accuracy up to 98
percent  in that part yes we
have managed to improve a
little bit we are already at points where
improving one point two points of precision
is a lot but what is more interesting
is that it has not destroyed it because in
dropbox and you wonder what we have
done has been to remove  a lot of
neurons in training how is it
possible that removing them has not broken it
not only has it not broken it but that
has helped to improve a bit the
precision
the loss of lacrosse primary center  mo
but
the over feet in is still big you only
raise there no matter how much we have
improved the curve that if we let it
grow it is huge if I add more cases it
will continue to grow
and here what we have clearly done is
that there is something that we have done
the castell is wrong and he starts reading I read all
the papers that were missing and then
you have too many neurons that are left over
neurons you have to remove and you can
do tests with the drop out you remove
drop out you put drop out you don't have
enough data man I think that
60,000 for the little numbers that we are
painting, you divide and he said you have a lot,
not 6000 for each case, I think it has
to be right what all the
literature says that we have enough
training cases and enough test cases
we have a poorly made network as we
have  the network is poorly made the network is not
the network is fine but if you remember what
we have done wrong not too bad is that
we have crushed all the data and
we have me  I put it in a vector,
that is, we took something in which
there was a drawing of an 8 and
we put it in a vector and we, well,
we weren't here, blessed, I
put it in a vector and it stayed so
wide, I mean  Suddenly something where I
had a 2d drawing I put it in a
vector was working for me by
chance
maqssa and it wasn't working by
chance I thought it was a line a
point and if it came close to 0 with 20
it was a 2 they are a fudge  we have to
go one step further and this is where
conventional networks help us which is
a convention a combo solution is a
functional operator that basically what
it does is the superposition of two
functions I like to explain it with
the optical part one  combo solution from an
optical point of view when you put two
lenses and they focus from a mathematical point of
view the way to achieve
that convolution would be the function of
each of the excellent ones and what
helps us is af  Fix the place where we are
seeing that would be the part on optics and
other explanations of course in
physics in mathematics of what a
composition is but in this case what we are
going to do is that we are going to take the
2d image with all the data  and we are going
to take a piece of that image and what
we are going to do is that
we are going to move that piece we are going to scan the
image taking patches okay for that what
we are going to do is define matrices
where we are going to put the data that goes
there and man before we have done the 0 and 1
of black and white we could put something
better not in this case as it is I had
put it here maarten is designed for
red green and blue in the drawing that
less than that not being able to put a little more
than  color that although it is something the grays
you will be able to improve in the
recognition okay
with that what we are going to do is
define a network that is going to do a
first layer of sampling and from
there a sampling we are going to define a few
layers  s of 5 x 5 in the first pack of that
we are going to draw a convention we are going to
put together several of those up to four in the
first of that we are going to take it to the
next one and we are going to define one in fact
and we are only going to take the  next we are
going to define one of 12 at the end we are going
to arrive at a matrix of 200 x 7 that is
200 x 7 x 7 x 12 and what we
finally want is the same software
that we had at the beginning that
was helping us to  to do to
find the values between 0 and 1 and that
art went on quite well here
ou have the code of how they would
be defined initialize and anne the varia
les you have the filter size would be the size
f the patch the input channel would be how m
ny channels I am taking data from and t
e  output channel would be the output channel
which is where we want to put the
data in this first one there are four in the
next one there are eight and in the last one there are
twelve which is the size of the convolution width
again tensor flow point nn
convolution to in  2d and that's what's
going to help us do the conduction
[Music]
believe me straits is the step the size of the
step here what we're doing is
going through the image one by one
pixel by pixel yes it's true that they are
what  better it could be optimized and
maybe do it two by two because if I
'm going to go through everything why I want to
generate so much information but well with
this set of data nothing happens either
and the skid is important to use
the same skid at all levels  which
basically is how much you are going to leave in the
surroundings,
we reset the function, the max use,
you see that defining the
code again is very easy,
perfect, you see how the cure has
risen, we are already at about 0 99,
the cross in  tropic has been bad for us
the cross entropy has not finished
the training digite is uploading again yes
we are recognizing them better the
cross en trope keeps uploading this
we have missed something of what we had
done before no yes  do you remember before
we said
if you remember before web sorry I went too
fast
if you remember before we had said that we
had to do a drop out so that it would not
upload we have left the drop to
when we have defined the function when we
defined it that martín  I had only
clearly left the drop out but notice that
we are already at 98 9 we are
practically at 99 which was the
objective we had initially we
have come very close and if you
remember the drop out what it is going to do
is it is going to help us  to win those 23
points that were the ones that we lacked
before, okay, and then what we do is once
again read each other how to make
the seizure patches that if
bigger, less big,
here
is that,
hello,
come on,
actually, we are in the
last step  we have already added the
conventions we are already above
99 percent and if you discount the
agrocentro pino it grows so much if you
also look at the training digits it will no longer
appear  There are errors because when doing the drop
out we have removed the few that
were missing to appear in the three
digits, we are already failing very
few, I miss the next one, that one has the
summary of everything, let's see,
thank you very much, we have already achieved
99.3, we have already  managed to exceed 99.3
which is what we have also achieved
that the drop out has taken away from us it has
reduced the errors that appear when we
advance in the data we are, we
have removed the over fitting and
with that what we have managed to reach
is not me  I'm giving to the world
[Music]
what we've managed to reach 99.3
short now because that's how it happens to people
back write a second if you think it's
a second
that the last levels I've seen the ones
who have achieved the most are 99.7
percent that is already  they are there surely there is
some more detail that can
be learned but you have
basically seen all the steps choose the
activation functions create the
how to create the model  or within tensor
flow of the neural network and how to pass the
data use drop out as a mechanism
to improve the loss in cruise in
tropic and control the
quality of the data quite well and without more than
passing the word pm medina which is one of
pepe medina is on the go you cover the cto
on laps clubs that apart from having a
name that is very difficult to pronounce as a
company what is interesting about it is
that they are doing things with tensor flow
very similar to these and wait and see
if we can get it you can take it to the
part  of the short fire or do you want to
cut the bolt part October
and
you really use this
[Music]
and we are using this
kruger boats for a project that I am going to
show now if I am able to reach
the presentation that I point to the
presentation that  It's my turn, but well,
I'm José Medina, the boat club ct
in Spain and director of the
boat club development center, he has here
in Madrid for everyone, for all of Europe,
I come to  present you a project that
really uses all these things so
simple that I have not explained here my
friend israel all this complexity of
technology
specifically for an example in the case
of the legal sector boat clubs
is a company that is very
difficult to pronounce for the
average  español is a Dutch company
that provides information services to
professionals in the legal
sector, the tax sector and the health sector,
we are in 40 countries, we have almost 20,000
employees that we use on the stock market in
amsterdam and what I am going to explain is
how we have  tried to apply this
technology and we have done it in a
specific problem in the field of
the legal sector, the legal professional
really faces a
very changing world in terms of
documentation the different bodies
generate millions of sentences they generate
hundreds of thousands of regulations at
different levels  at the national level at
the regional level at the local level and this is
the  The problem that
professionals in the legal sector
face every day,
what is the real problem in which
the client is the client of the jurist,
because when one goes to the lawyer,
as when one goes to the doctor, the first
thing he asks is a doctor  My case is very
serious, what possibilities do I have and
lastly, normally, how much time do I have
left if things go wrong and what does
the jurist do, because the jurist basically
responds based on his
experience, personal experience in that type of case
in that court in that  situation or
consultation with colleagues who have
experiences in cases in similar cases
that we have done to help the
professional in this sense we have
applied the technology called
artificial intelligence which, as you
can see,
is software
to be able to extract, analyze and extract
all that information from the texts  that
we already have to be able to answer the
questions but with data and with
clear and information-based guidelines.
objective ion the what is clubs
manage thousands and millions of sentences
stored for years where all this
information already exists that information
is in the text the only difference is that
you have to read it to interpret it of course
one cannot read millions of
sentences to be able to respond  to these
questions what we have used is
technologies such as the one you have seen
before to be able to extract that information
in an automated way and to be able to
respond, for example with apps such
as natural in wing processing
we are extracting entities such as the
name of the lawyers the typification of
the  attorneys, the companies that
participate, the amounts of the sentence,
etc., etc. With tensor flow
we are training models to be able to
extract and extract
the meaning of the ruling from the different sentences, for
example with sentimental analysis models
or we are training
hundreds of very complex models to be
able to identify
when  a sentence was in favor or in
Against one part, what type of
procedure did I use, what was the
specific application of that sentence,
because we can do this, because we can
train the models that you have seen
before, we start from the fact that bolt is a club,
it has millions of sentences
stored in the systems that we have
been training manually.  for years
we started from those few hundred thousand
to deliver models that allow us to
automatically analyze the rest
of the millions that give us a
statistical base to generate information that
is reliable
juristics it is called the project it is
called a product and what it does is
put together all this information that
we have extracted from that enormous volume of data
in conjunction with the
analytical information that we already have in an
objective way to be able to give an answer and for
the lawyer to give an answer to the question
that he is asking is a client
we can predict times  we can
predict probabilities we can predict
the likely outcome of the  resolution
of the problem and above all we can
predict
for the specific court in which your
case is going to be dealt with and even for the
judge in conclusion and this is a
personal conclusion
this triple er ning technology is not an
end in itself all that we have
seen before is not an objective in
itself I have seen many companies
that have applied team
learning technology per se, that is, we are going to bring it
to see what it contributes without wanting to solve a
specific problem without wanting to solve
a specific case or development and this
is generating  frustration and can
generate a false expectation
martin lenin's technology offers
enormous power but it does not solve
problems per se you have to know it
and you have to know where to apply it and you have
to use it where it is necessary to
use it
for which not
here this is a little  the concept of the
product that we bring you and this is a
video that shows if I am able to get
here what is the type of product that
we are d  edeveloping juri metrics
the clients of the drafts
of vision problems
the balance is night you need
perimetry to the decision making
weekly graphically
demonstrate balance technology white of the
world league argumentation preserved the
state of beige a projectile network cyber
english life of zack 66 jones
i
instead they are innovative material singer
and media and experience their
professional production is a vile
sedena elements of extraction
and the fast food nation
juri meta is that breaking april
april
juri metry 210 molds club is your best
partner
and this is  a case of how to apply
technology to solve
real customer problems how to get value
from the tensor flow technology that google
offers us thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]